hey everybody huge news they just
confirmed that danny elfman is going to
be scoring justice league so there's a
whole bunch of stuff that comes with
that but I'll do a preview for some of
his older classic themes because you
probably remember him from at least one
big thing either Batman spider-man or
even the flash TV show new brand of the
flash ring giveaway - all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video there isn't really
any drama behind the decision to go with
Danny Elfman / junkie XL but if you
weren't aware junkie XL was the composer
to the Zack Snyder brought on for Batman
V Superman who was also already working
on the score for Justice League when
they hired Danny Elfman it sounds like a
bigger thing that it actually is but
this is the statement that he issued
like he tweeted this out yesterday right
after they made the Danny Elfman
announcement so he said as my mentor
Hans Zimmer told me you haven't made it
in Hollywood as a composer until you get
replaced on a project so I guess I
finally graduated this week it pains me
to leave the project but a big thanks to
Zach for asking me to be part of his
vision and I wish Danny jaws and Warner
Brothers all the best with Justice
League signed Tom Tom is just his real
name
so we hadn't heard any of his Justice
League theme song like he hadn't teased
any of it so we don't know how different
it was gonna be from Batman be a
Superman this is what that sounded like
he also had a hand in developing the
Wonder Woman theme - because that was
done for Batman V Superman and then
later reused during the Wonder Woman
movie so again it's not that he's
getting fired off of Justice League
because Joss Whedon is coming in that's
more of a studio decision and I think
the reason they're going with Danny
Elfman is because they want the tone to
be a little bit lighter think about the
spider-man theme song think about the
Batman theme song that he's done so I'll
play some of those in a second for
comparison but they just tend to be a
little bit more magical a little bit
more traditional big Orchestra you
probably heard all the talk last year
about the creative retooling for Justice
League in the DC films going forward
after the critical response to Batman V
Superman I don't think that was as big a
deal as people were making it out to be
but based on junkie XL statement they
were very clearly planning on going in a
different direction originally but
people get replaced
on big movies like this all the time
it's just that you don't hear about it
as often writers get replaced several
times through the creative process
they've gone through three different
black movies scripts in to directors
they still haven't landed on their third
yet but it does sound like it's going to
be Robert Zemeckis so things change
behind the scenes all the time and I'm a
huge fan of Danny Elfman so I feel like
if you were gonna go with a really big
superhero movie composer he would be the
guy to go to but here's a little bit
from his Batman and his spider-man
themes for comparison
[Music]
so all this Danny Elfman's stuff is good
news it might sound like there's drama
behind the scenes but there's no drama
it's not that big a deal and Zack Snyder
just tweeted out this anniversary
picture of a Superman back during Man of
Steel and they've been doing a couple of
reshoots it looks like they're shooting
some Wonder Woman flashbacks they're
shooting some Gotham scenes the actress
that plays iris West and the DCE you
said that she just filmed her cameo so
there's still a couple things that
they're doing on Justice League you'll
probably hear more about that as we get
closer to comic-con and yes they will be
dropping new Justice League footage at
Comic Con there's foot